[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link it's time for another
conversation with an interesting person
from the internet this week that person
is Brooke Dodger Leigh Lawson arguably
the most well known girl gamer on you -
yes we have a fascinating conversation
covering her small-town roots in her
sword collection the challenges of being
a female in the male-dominated world of
gaming and what's caused her to cry and
two of her vlogs here's a head it has
something to do with a recent bombshell
she dropped relating to her love life
now I got to admit I'm a little
intimidated in talking to Dodger because
I'm a little intimidated and talking to
anyone already happened you're still
intimidated yeah we know that we're
talking we just tease the things that
we're talking about yeah I'm saying but
know that I'm saying that the process of
talking to someone who is a game where
intimate is an intimidating thing
because it's such a big part of the
YouTube culture now you know everybody's
got a gaming channel everybody cares
about games and we're not everybody we
don't and that's your point we're kind
of disconnected we kind of feel like old
farts well when it comes to this or just
out of the know but I will say that you
know I also like to have a certain sense
of pride of being one of those guys that
you know when the original NES came out
like I was a child who experienced that
as a child at Christmas I specifically
remember it was probably Christmas 1986
a maven 87 I don't it was the year that
it was out in the US and that people
were getting up for that first Christmas
so I guess 86 and you know I got at the
same time my stepfather at the time
Jimmy was just as excited as I was
everybody that's a weird thing because
my parents weren't even the kind of
parents who were into that kind of thing
that they would get you the thing yeah I
never it was the kid that got the thing
that everybody was getting but that year
for whatever reason they're like
well I guess we got to get this thing
because everybody's getting this thing
and so there it was you know when I woke
up and I remember you know it came with
Mario Brothers and then duck hunt did
you get the power pad you got the power
pad no I did not get the power bed I
didn't either and I didn't really care
but I just remember specifically Super
Mario Brothers man I I played that with
my we played that all day and then my
parents came up and they said you've got
to go to bed and I remember thinking
that no you don't understand mom my life
has just changed like the fam not ever
gonna sleep in here that this exists
that's something that is so unbelievably
I mean did you have an Atari I had an
Atari I mean it wasn't like yeah yeah
but it was enough there was no
comparison yeah that's true there was no
comparison
and then I would you know I would go
over to your house and you're like I got
this gold one called Legend of Zelda I
mean is gold one I I you know take it or
leave it
so what the main character is my name I
have never played it never and that's
sad and I'm ashamed of that you should
be I said and you should be ashamed
last night Lincoln put it on his DS like
the old-school version we got it for
like five bucks so I think I'm me play
Zelda for the first time it's like that
viral video from a few months back where
Mike Tyson played Mike Tyson's punch-out
for the first time in the ESPN Lobby
it's a little different because that
game was kind of built around him
actually oh that's not actually me I
mean people ask me when they meet me Oh
your name's linka yeah I was like they
name the game after me they believe me
or sometimes I say the opposite which
can't be true because I'm too old for
that
right but that keep many people thinking
either way it's not true but I mean
you're gonna I'm gonna go and tell you
right now I mean as much as I love that
game you're gonna be disappointed I mean
you first of all you'll never play it to
the the amount of time the amount of
gameplay that goes into any Zelda game
it's not something that you just like my
son's got a yes that's why I never
played it in the first place because I
couldn't beat Mario Brothers I just
didn't have the commitment or the the
where
to stick with something that didn't need
commitment you needed Chad Landrum that
was your problem
yeah I didn't Landrum had a subscription
to Nintendo Power and he was the key if
you wanted to beat something first of
all I mean Mario you couldn't beat Mario
Brothers now there's a problem it's just
a personal problem I mean you know your
wife can be Super Mario Brothers in like
seven minutes I've seen her do it and
and I'm I'm married to her so why do I
need to do it she completes me right
it's romantic but when it comes to
something as complex as you know the
first Zelda and then you know the
subsequent games I can't handle that you
you had to have a Nintendo Power or -
Chad Landrum now contra I would go to
you it's funny I would go I had a
Nintendo but I would go to your house
and play none - no yeah what contra was
great that was revolutionary for me
because then I could like ride the
coattails of someone simultaneously okay
you get in front with that spread gun
and I'll just kind of hang back and take
the credit you know that's a good game
well I can never beat contra we never be
contra though that's difficult I made it
not even with 34 men 30 no we each had
30 oh well it didn't happen and yeah
yeah but I didn't get into a lot of
other games I mean I got the Genesis
when that came out but I still I just I
was such a shall I only waiting in the
shallow end of video gaming you were
afraid to go all and you were afraid to
commit it's amazing at how how pervasive
it is now the culture and I mean not
only obviously to YouTube I mean you
look at the top videos and it's just
there it's pervasive there's no other
way to say it that they are everywhere
and it's an entire business that's just
it's mind-boggling well and I've gone
you know I spent the first couple years
that we were on YouTube with this
mentality that when I saw something
working I was either jealous of it or
just frustrated that it was working and
I didn't understand why it was working
now my life has become one you know one
realization after another like oh this
is what's working now I'm not going to
question it people like watching people
play video games okay
maybe I don't I understand that people
do I understand that a lot of people do
so I'm probably even in the minority in
it so I'm not gonna sit around and make
fun of it I'm gonna embrace it as this
is the reality now the most popular
youtuber out there is a let's play gamer
PewDiePie
he's not on the show but the female
gamer arguably is and like I said we had
a fascinating conversation with her even
though we might have been in the dark
she was very gracious with us and I
think whether you're into gaming or not
I think there's lots to learn here and I
think you will enjoy it
the Adagio is a rising star and this
massive growing community of video game
vloggers and gamers she's the face of
makers new gaming channel Polaris and I
always want to say Polaris but it's
Polaris at Polaris is like an ATV
company right I don't know yes and also
she maintains her own two channels press
heart to continue on which she dishes
out weekly industry updates and
dexterity bonus which features daily
personal content she's also one of our
favorite guests from the mythical show
you may remember her from the most
complicated board game ever she milked
herself yes she did and here we go you
said Oregon so that's how is that where
you were born that's home yeah I lived
there my whole life before I moved here
now is there a trail that ends there oh
what's the deal there is a trail there's
actually a huge I really want to have a
house and don't don't if you if you go
to Oregon if you go to the the Clackamas
County Oregon City area there's there's
a city called Oregon City I'm not just
saying cities of Oregon but there's a
huge wagon where the trail quote ended
end quote so there's a big there's a big
maybe BIG's the wrong word there's a
museum there next to the wagon and they
teach you how to make butter really all
the yeah all the kids wind up having a
field trip there now do you play Oregon
Trail with a special sense of pride we
did play that game a lot yeah
in which version are we talking about
here because we and you know world we
played the the Apple yeah the green hue
during text on you know on the 87
version I actually can't remember what
the version was that we played when I
was a kid but I know that I never made
it ever I never once made it all the way
to the dysentery
yeah I'm just know that there wasn't end
I thought that the game was just being
on a trail just living yeah I think
that's what everyone said frontier life
who was doing it that was the rationale
yeah there is no destination right let's
just not let's not die while 40 in this
river
simple as that let's take it one River
how many more days can you live this
time so what is what we're in Oregon
well you did you grow up where where um
I grew up in a little town called
Molalla it's very small Malala Malala
it's named after a Native American tribe
of which there are none left I believe
there was one woman who is left in town
and I think I think she's gone now but
it's a very small town very very small
and I lived there my whole life until
college and then I went to another very
tiny town called Monmouth and lived
there for all of college and then in
Oregon yeah and then I was offered a job
in LA so what's cool is only one small
Western Oregon University it is one of
two colleges in Oregon that have a
Bachelor of Fine Arts in theater and
that's what I wanted so okay I went to
the one that was a little less hectic
because Southern Oregon University is
where the Oregon Shakespeare Festival is
so it's like crazy all the time so I
went to Western Oregon and said and it's
only an hour away from where I lived and
how big was it mo was the student
Western Oregon do ya
Western Oregon was 5000 oh okay I think
okay it was pretty small mm-hmm so so
what was the growing up situation you to
be talking both parents
yeah knocks both both parents and ox
there's no box but we did have we had
chickens we had a bunch of horses we had
bunnies there were pigs before I came
into the picture we got two sheep that
were awful while I was a kid and we
wound up giving them to somebody else
but I also have two siblings
what makes an a sheep awful they okay so
sheep may not know this some sheep were
very sweet some sheep are just so honoré
they'll do whatever they want hmm so we
had these sheep that broke down our
fences constantly and they would just
escape and then they'd come back and
they'd ruin the fields they'd get all
over the place so we had a really hard
time controlling them unfortunately got
a control sheep out of control sheep
horses like can break down fences but
their their bodies are shaped a bit
differently so it's like harder for them
to I don't know bust down a fence a bus
yeah because with the Sheep like they're
just like this compact muscle body and
they just like Ram themselves into it
and then they're gone I thought that was
wool that's muscle that's not all muscle
there's no wool they're thin layer of
wool it's like evidence thick so this is
like a bonafide farm situation yeah I
grew up on a farm so are there were
there crops grown or was it just like oh
we love animals and we have a lot of
land situation we grew grass hay and
oats a couple of years but it was mostly
grass hay so and then you would sell
that to people who wanted to feed their
fill-in-the-blanks the intention was to
sell it but we didn't have the necessary
equipment to be able to bail it so we
had a neighbor who had a ton of cows and
we had our horses and so he would come
bail it and then we would split it okay
so we actually didn't sell it we just
grew it for lols and for animals what
was this I mean this your source of
sustenance I mean was your mom or dad
doing something else at the time or they
didn't eat it well I know I mean we ate
the grass a-and and the horses now
my mom worked full-time my entire life
and my dad maintained the fireman raise
the kids so so what did your mom do my
mom was Human Resources at a grocery
store called Fred Meijer well it was a
department store actually so she did
that employee discount oh yeah
oh man we would go there all the time
and be like so it's not food it's colors
it's a department store so there's
there's lots of food there there's lots
of clothes there but we didn't have one
close enough to us where we could get
perishables so normally when we would go
all the way there it would be to get
clothes and stuff so growing up on a
farm you know I have to assume that's
something like my brother stuck his hand
in a horse's mouth and lost a finger
like you know right and you grew up in
that situation that kind of stuff just
occasionally happens because you love to
hear about it sure you want to hear one
digit we got to know my brother when
they first bought the farm was running
through the forest because we're
surrounded by woods at my house so he
was running through the forest fell and
then heard my dad calling for him got up
and came out of the forest and my dad
looked at his arm and there was just
blood everywhere my brother hadn't
noticed he hadn't even felt it happen
but there was a machete in the middle of
the woods that he had fallen on of
course and now he has a scar from his
elbow all the way down to his wrist
sliced him it sliced him open and he
didn't realize it and he did not feel it
it was very strange so then it was my
mom and my dad rushing him to the
hospital and my dad holding onto his arm
like keeping it together yeah yeah yep
you didn't employ a sheep for that there
was no sheep involved no she knew sheep
were involved in this story just wrap
this thing up in a wool weird stuff in
the woods out there though there was
also a the remnants of a shack and I
used to go out there and play all the
time like a lone yeah and I'm pretty
sure if my dad knew that I was playing
in an old shack he would have been can
but I didn't I mean as kids Ren I would
go into the you know there's assorted
pockets of woods around Buies Creek
North Carolina and you can manage to
find like a like an old shack or
something and it was always very spooky
and very cool kind of to kind of go into
those run-down buildings it was it was a
I would go so far as to call it a
pastime but I would not have done it
alone
yeah I would have been - to - who
creeped out yeah you got to have a buddy
for that situation so I'm good for you I
mean you going in those because it has
to be creepy well they're not I mean
when I say shack it's not it wasn't put
together enough to still look like a
shack it was busted you know but yeah I
you know I was so used to those woods I
grew up there like I was born near that
farm and was raised on that farm so as I
got older I just went further and
further into the woods so it didn't seem
as creepy to me I don't think so a
bonafide farm girl type situation yeah
with you said you had a brother who
siblings a brother and a sister
both older both older my sister is 17
years older than me and my brother is 11
years older than me
really yeah that's quite a spread yeah
yep so my sister was basically out of
the house
by the time I was like up and walking
around and able to understand what
things were mm-hmm and you so you and
your brother I imagine were that close
if he was that much older - we're really
close now and as kids I loved him so
much I wanted to be just like my brother
and he was so annoyed by me I would do
the most obnoxious sister things like I
would sit in front of his room while he
was sleeping cuz he would sleep in but
everybody else on the farm would wake up
at like 6:00 so I would sit outside of
his room waiting for him to wake up
because I wanted to play supermario or
just just hang out with him I want to
build a snowman yeah it was basically
that have you seen that yeah I have seen
that it's very good pretty good
qe so you mentioned Mario Brothers now
so growing up on the farm right he
obviously were not discouraged from
playing video games
it wasn't hey don't you go outside and
pet a sheep you can find a career in
this video game thing so get to it young
lady
no I mean my dad farmville anyone long
my dad felt very strongly that everybody
should be helping out outside so it was
you know it's fine for you to play games
it's fine for you to be on the computer
but you that can't be all you're doing
you know so I my jobs were weeding and
picking up acorns and just the tedious
awful jobs every now and then I got to
cut wood that was a bit more interesting
but no my dad picking up acorns why
would one do that because they would get
all over our driveway and then when you
would drive over them they would just be
crushed on the driveway and it just
didn't look good and they're poisonous
and poisonous yeah hey you look at me
like I'm crazy
acorns are poisonous google that and
then tell me that I'm right and then the
other thing is is that we're not gonna
Google it don't worry about you boil if
you cook them or boil them they are no
longer poisonous and then you can drink
a corn tea which I'm drinking right now
okay by the way the fact that I'm
drinking it so when was the inception of
the videogames into your life that you
know how do we trace that back to being
something that I I assume you would say
is a life changing now right yeah I mean
games have been my life my whole life I
feel like my dad is still obsessed with
Tetris to play it all the time like oh
and what a gameboy no NES original
Nintendo he still has it he has a
replacement NES in case the one he's
using breaks he has replacement
controllers just a played Tetris to play
Tetris the little screen that's in the
garage because my dad's garage is like
where he hangs out when he's not working
outside so the little TV that he has in
there
the you failed screen burned into it so
anytime you look at that TV it looks
like the game is on but it's not it's
burned that heart into the screen well
that must mean that he would leave it on
that screen mm-hmm yeah because he would
taunt himself he would play it all the
time and when it when he would die I'd
be like all right back to work and he'd
get up and go work and it was just
sitting there just there yeah you failed
you failed you failed you failed you
failed Matlock and Perry Mason and and
play Tetris in tandem oh yeah
of course it hasn't upgraded though I
mean he's still he's not he doesn't want
more buttons no absolutely not I mean he
he understands this system you know have
you ever shown him or tried to get him
to play a new system oh yeah I mean he's
played other games with us but but the
original Tetris is his well because he
keeps going back to it it never gets old
now I I think the the sad fact of the
matter is just just to be totally honest
with you here is that we're we're right
there with your dad so for the rest of
this conversation you're just gonna have
to bear with us you're you okay so I
could just make stuff up our hope is
that you will be our Sherpa on this
Oregon Trail of gaming but we do have
kids now and my kids are introducing me
back into the world of gaming so it's
it's interesting how that that's
happening cuz I kind of missed the
window with the the 16 button
controllers that was just a too much
right I feel like there was a big period
of time where a lot of really good games
came out that I did not play at all like
kind of when I when I was in high school
mostly when I was in high school I just
never really played any new games at all
and so now sometimes when I'm when I'm
working with colleagues or just talking
with friends and they're like oh man
that game right such a good game I can't
contribute at all I don't so what was
happening in your life in that like
growing up what are pivotal moments from
the picking up acorns
through the high school years I think
high school is when I started to feel
like I shouldn't ask my parents for
things like I should get a job and start
trying to pay for things myself but I
was involved in a lot of extracurricular
activities so I didn't really have time
to have a job but because of that I
still if there was something if there
was a game that came out that I was
interested in playing I just wouldn't
ask for it
so once I got into college and I was
making like a little bit of extra money
I started playing more games again okay
so so what was life like in that in that
time period for you in high school yeah
like lots of theater heck you know girl
yeah that's that's what I studied in
college too right so I was doing a lot
of plays I was on dance team doing dance
team I tried to do a play dance team and
the tennis team all at the same time
that does not work out drop tennis real
quick but the plays were always really
fun that's usually not a combination
that you see though you don't normally
know someone who's on the tennis team
and the dance team and in theater at the
same time typically there are some for
better for worse there are some cliques
right in high school you know yeah our
school is actually really good about
that
um the kids that I would say were the
popular kids we're all for the most part
really nice there wasn't a lot of
bullying that happened in my school and
even the kids that that got kind of
teased had a lot of friends had a lot of
good positivity and I don't know if
that's because I went to a smaller high
school as well but we didn't we didn't
really have a whole lot of problems with
cliques so I think people felt more like
they were able to try things I guess so
as a theater kid yes were you thinking
this is it I mean obviously to the point
where you wanted to go study in college
where you what was the aspiration there
what did you want to do ultimately um I
liked doing all of it which wound up
being a problem because like I said I
went to Western Oregon for their
Bachelor of Fine Arts program and that
be
tickly means you choose one thing that
you want to do and you study it real
hard like all of your classes have to do
with it
mm-hm so I decided well go for for The
Bachelor of Fine Arts and acting and I
did and I got in there were only two of
us that got in and I was really excited
I was so jazzed but every term I wanted
to be designing costumes and I wanted to
be helping with building sets and I
wanted to be doing other things that
were adjacent to acting but weren't
acting in the shows and I was basically
sat down by my adviser and he said you
need to decide whether or not this is
what you want to do if this is the
program for you and if it's not then
just drop it I mean you can you can
still be in our department but I don't
think that this program is good for you
so I wound up dropping it and then I got
to design an act and it was great what
kind of what kind of plays were you
involved in what kind of roles did you
play what did you gravitate towards um I
played a lot of nervous people I played
a lot of really crazy people do you
volunteer for that or they spotted
something in you I was definitely never
the the standard female lead or like the
sweet ingenue I was always a little
strange all of my characters were always
strange but it was it was really fun
because then you got to kind of pinpoint
something to to bring out of that
character you know you got to be a
little bit larger than life and I always
really enjoyed that so I think that was
there something does it say something
about you that you gravitated towards
those roles I think so I didn't do very
well with roles this is gonna sound
awful I didn't do very well with roles
that were supposed to be very honest
like roles where you needed to put a lot
of genuine emotion into it I guess like
that was always very hard for me it was
very hard for me to be in the moment
when it was a very real feeling but if I
was somebody who was kind of outside of
the norm
it was a little bit easier for me to
justify what that feeling would be don't
like any sense does it that was such a
strange way to explain that but kind of
take an angle like okay in this instance
I'm I'm gonna be the lying evil person
or the weird crazy person versus the
person who's about to break down and cry
like it's yeah it's the difference
between being the completely normal girl
who's upset about something versus the
straight-up crazy villain maybe
character actor yeah I think that those
are more engaging they're just more fun
and it's easier to connect with them for
me for some reason okay
did you intend to go on and do something
with theatre after college yet an actor
yeah I mean if like YouTube is literally
the reason I'm in LA so if if YouTube
hadn't happened I was fully prepared to
be making coffee most of the time and in
turning out whatever theater would take
me until they would actually hire me
that was like the big plan or theater
we're in Oregon in Oregon yeah you can I
wouldn't I wouldn't have had the money
to go anywhere else
so you kind of you felt like okay just
because of finances I'm gonna be staying
around here and I'm gonna attach myself
to some some theater company type
situation yeah yeah I had I had interned
a little bit during college at different
theaters in Portland and so I thought
well I can keep doing that sort of a
thing have a job on the side and
hopefully eventually endear myself
enough to and one of these companies
that they they take me on and actually
pay me and then move from there but the
other option was to go to grad school
and learn how to make armor that was
like my big thing that I wanted to do
okay armor yeah now so that's that seems
now when you say that all of us in us
okay that seems expected like that's a
decidedly geeky right so was where you
uh would you label yourself as a geek at
that point or I mean when you're into
armor
if I'm okay one of my career goals is I
might go into making armor yeah it was
because I mean yeah I've always I've
always been interested in an armor and
like LARPing like I loved making fake
swords and stuff and beating up my
friends so you barked yeah Oh full-on in
high school but oh okay well hold on we
got to talk about sorry okay because I
mean this is something that we have
definitely referenced many a time and a
few different videos in the comedy
context but I don't think I've ever
tunity for LARPing in Oregon know what
open space why that's why yeah there you
know people got fields you're able to if
you all if you've got the round balers
okay so here's what you got to do you
got to find somebody who's using round
bales instead of square bales and then
you can turn those into targets and you
can have archery oh wow and you did this
uh no we wanted to many people do you
need to LARP and then how did you
organize that you don't need that many
people at all it's I mean yeah he's live
in by infinity you just create an
adventure for yourself you know it's
just like some people play D&D by
themselves and you think how do they do
that they don't even have a dungeon
master but you can do it but like with
with kind of the LARPing that happened
with us it was basically a group of
friends just a bunch of us we all
thought that it sounded like a lot of
fun to just you know take a day and I'll
make our swords and then you know dress
up in whatever we had and then go out
into the backyard at one of our houses
and just you know attack each other like
that's literally as far as it went it
wasn't super organized it wasn't like a
group person wasn't like I hit you with
my sword you're out oh it was it was it
was that one out glorified tag yeah
basic tag with fake swords it was great
no no judgement
I don't exactly mean I
the origins of LARPing or because when
we talking about when when you were when
were you in high school I graduated 2005
so I started doing this 2003 so this is
I mean I guess there's there's been
somewhat of a LARPing ro revolution
right this seems like this is probably
right in the throes of that or maybe the
beginnings of that right this is kind of
thing you're like did you hear about
what those people are doing they're
they're LARPing and we can also do that
maybe I don't feel like I knew of
anybody else who was doing that we were
just all kind of bored there wasn't
really anything to do a LARPing no
that's kind of what I was getting at was
this is the kind of thing that the right
group of people it could just spawn
right you know and it'll RP didn't know
ended it we were the first in your minds
yeah I mean it just sounded like fun so
we just did it yeah so by the time
you're thinking about graduate school
it's like on steroids you're like I can
make actual armor there are people who
do this yeah cuz at that point I had
spent my entire senior year focusing a
lot on costume crafts and props so I had
made like puppets and dead bodies and
all sorts of weird stuff and when I was
looking into grad schools one of the
coolest ones had this huge program where
they were like we'll teach you how to
make legit armor swords anything like
that and I wanted to go there so bad
do you own a sword now I own have you
realized this dream this is actually
really funny I just took a picture
because I have all of my swords on my
kitchen floor right now just like
sitting there because I don't have any
I've been going through all my stuff and
I don't know where to put my swords so
they've just been in my kitchen I have
okay stuff with him one heck of a peanut
butter and jelly so you know yeah I have
Zelda Master Sword I have my APA from
when I was in college and took a stage
fighting I have a katana I have like an
old style wooden sword that someone sent
me and
well while you're thinking about that
have you been to sword in stone here in
Burbank
no oh she hasn't been I mean this is
he's a forger of swords this is the guy
he hasn't he has a web series where he
he forges he's a blacksmith and he
forges the recreations it's that sort of
famous weapons from different movies and
shows and stuff but he's also he goes
way back he made Conan's sword old Conan
he pin it's in the shop and he's got all
kinds of stuff like that and it's right
here in Burbank we shot some scenes for
a video but uh as I was in there I
definitely had this sensation that like
I think this is awesome but should be it
would really really appreciate this more
you should go there you have to go yeah
yeah to go that sounds awesome but we
digress okay so you decided right well
and what happened at that point when you
were looking at graduate school and
theater around Oregon like why did I do
YouTube yeah how did that well YouTube
happened because I had a couple of
friends who were doing YouTube one of
them was being very successful at it and
I was bored out of my mind husky
Starcraft okay so I was taking my very
last class to get my degree it was math
his summer I had a part-time job at Huff
farm and I just had a lot of free time
and I didn't know what to do with it and
it was suggested to me that I try making
a YouTube channel and so I was looking
to see what other ladies were doing in
the gaming world on YouTube and not many
people really had like consistent shows
or were doing much of anything so I
decided to try doing just a news show
and doing it every other day and in what
year was this graduate 2010 okay so this
is sort of before let's play just
took over but it was it was before let's
play really took over yeah but but it
was catching it was catching it yeah and
so what was big gameplay in general so
like not necessarily Let's Plays or
walkthroughs or playthroughs of an
entire game but watching people play a
game oh let's see we were kind of we
thought it was the same thing yeah yeah
I mean just basically someone playing a
video gaming and talking over the top of
it well I mean what the code is at this
point is not just let's play what's the
proper terminology let's play let's play
is is a series in which you play an
entire game okay whereas just gameplay
would be just a scene or a part of a
game doesn't necessarily have to be the
entire game but in form it's the same
thing it's just a question of is it can
complete or not is it going to continue
could you watch it from the beginning
and could you see the end so it was
really I mean so husky Starcraft he was
very successful and a friend of yours
yeah yeah he and I went to the same high
school and yeah and we were we we kind
of reconnected in college and we were
chatting and I went and looked at his
YouTube channel I was like whoa you get
a lot of views people love watching this
and he was like yeah cuz he basically he
would just bring up professional
Starcraft matches and he would
commentate over them like ESPN style and
that's that's what he continues to do
that's what a lot of guys do for a lot
of eSports right now and it's big it's
huge but he got in kind of on the ground
floor of the newer Starcraft game so he
just blew up he was a friendly or some
high school towards the end of college
you're talking with him is he the one
who's saying hey you need to get in on
this what's funny is it was actually
originally he thought that my brother
should have a YouTube channel because my
brother is a incredible singer okay
edible pianist and so my brother was
like no not my brother sorry Mike I'm
husky okay I said that
you know music is real hot on YouTube he
was like if you know Jared wants to try
that out he should totally do it
and Jared you know made like a couple of
videos but he was like that's whatever
and wound up making one myself instead
she's really but I can do it I was like
that sounds fun I'm bored
oh yeah I'll try it and you're like why
didn't you tell me to make a youtube
channel why are you talking about my
brother
nah it's interesting you said that you
looked at kind of the landscape of how
many girls were doing it are not doing
it that so you tell me that was kind of
a part of your initial analysis of an
opportunity for you even from the
beginning kind of just not I wasn't
going into it thinking this could be a
career but I was looking at it from the
standpoint of pretty much everybody who
had said hey you should think about
making a YouTube channel said oh a girl
doing video game stuff that would do
really well you know just the
stereotypical thing mhm and I wanted to
see how how girls were doing on YouTube
in the gaming world like what were they
doing how how is it going about and so
what did you find specifically when you
look that way I found a lot of
inconsistency like a lot of people who
would make one video every month or two
months and didn't really have a clear
focus on what they were doing so and you
couldn't find any girl that you okay I'm
gonna emulate what she's doing not
really I mean I picked I picked and
choose some things like I knew I didn't
want to be this is gonna sound awful but
I knew I didn't want to be another girl
who was aiming a camera at my boobs
didn't want to do that I knew that I
didn't I think that's always an accident
Oh
always always obviously uh you know it's
they were just why I mean why yeah why
for you was that important I mean yeah
some girls make that choice it's
effective yeah you could have made that
choice yeah what
what was behind that choice for you um I
wanted my videos to be as much about
what I was saying as possible and you
usually say them from your mouth I say
them from my mouth so yeah and I I just
like being friends with mostly guys at
the time it was interesting discussing
it with them because all of them
unanimously said oh yeah of course I
would watch that but they also all
unanimously didn't respect the person
that they were watching hmm and that was
not something I wanted at all I wanted
to know that if I was going to be making
videos especially about news like the
gaming industry I wanted to know that
that my opinions were going to matter at
all if that makes sense yeah so what was
the I mean was the first video the first
video is so weird to go through boobs
right it was just it was just boobs I
don't know what happened
no the very first video was was me just
like sitting with like this strange
camera from like here but like it was
just like this weird light higher up
yeah just like my face and I talked in a
slightly higher pitched voice and I
don't know why that was good it's it's
very weird to go back because I'm like
why was I doing that that sounds so
strange but you know it's your first
videos when you're kind of like nervous
and I'm really sure what you're doing
and now I'm so comfortable with the
camera it's just like hey guys I'm
farting right now that's kind of nice
that's happened I missed that one oh
yeah I actually like I come from a
couple of days ago I made a video and at
the end of the video I was like gosh
guys this whole this whole time that
I've been talking to you I felt like
there's a fart brewing I did it hasn't
happened and it was distracting me
through the whole video I was like god I
just feel like there's a fart and it's
not happening it was it was very
distracting so I figured I'd just like
let them know but you get camera
didn't let it go it never never had like
a new Foley for that what for put the
phone up to the camera
mm-hmm okay so sorry what did you say
what this was was it news video game
news yeah it was I talked about and you
named you started you know press hard to
continue you you thought through the
branding of all this you're like I'm
gonna call it this I'm gonna shoot from
a slightly high angle I'm gonna talk a
little bit higher pitch in what in and
you talk about what I talked about game
companies I talked about game releases
they talked about really just the same
sort of things that people write
articles about except I was making a
video instead so yeah and and I've I've
switched formats at this point like at
that time I was doing three topics every
other day so like each video I would
cover three different things and now
I've I've switched it so that I do the
video once a week and I cover six topics
so that I'm able to kind of focus on the
things the most important things that
happened that week rather than just
having weird filler people like oh
there's a katamari body pillow day you
should buy so so so what was the
transition from deciding to make the
first video to being able to move to LA
and make a career out of it so I kept
making the videos and maker was putting
together their gaming vertical and where
you were like still kind of in college
like last semester yeah I I was just
finishing up my class and I was
contacted by maker and they said hey we
are going to be doing a launch of you
know just like a few gaming channels to
start with and we know that you're small
but we feel like you're getting better
with each video
you know we'd like to have you involved
from the start if you're interested and
I said sure so they launched the
vertical and I was part of it and then a
couple of months later I was called
again and they said we're actually
looking for people who want to do
network development for this vertical
and if you're interested there's a job
for you in LA if you want it and so I
said okay because in my mind that was
like way better than making coffee and
trying desperately to get a job in a
theater so maybe even making armor or
maybe maybe I don't know making our
movie so dope right I don't know if you
can beat that what's it like being a
girl in a guy's world of gaming
I mean I'm hard pressed to find any any
girls to compare you to even now right I
mean I'm not that familiar with the
space but you're still very unique as a
female immersed in the gaming culture in
this way there are some of us there are
a few of us and I think there are more
and more I think there are a lot more
women getting involved in the more like
journalistic side of it like on various
websites that do articles in gaming more
and more girls are getting involved in
that and well you know you obviously
respect your audience and it's you you
expect them to to be intelligent and you
because you know that of them so you
respect that in them you're not you're
not buying into the programming down to
people so but that being said there's
still a lot of guys are you know still
pigs kind of a thing I think of course I
would imagine that there's still it's
hard it's got to be hard for you at
times being being a female in the
position you're in when so much of your
audience are these guys who you know
with commenting you can say anything
they want I mean how do you
how difficult does it get and how do you
navigate that it doesn't get difficult I
don't think because in the end we're all
used to getting some brand of negative
comments but it's always the minority
and I count really misogynistic comments
within negative comments and I think the
key is just focusing on the vast
majority of your consistent viewers that
really love what you do and do respect
you you know and so well if I do see
somebody who says something totally out
of line I can block them for the most
part it's like I I don't really see them
and I know they exist but it doesn't
affect my quality of life or the quality
of my content or the quality of my
community because I know that for the
most part they're all wonderful
intelligent and they like what I'm doing
so there takes a lot of strength to be
able to do that now another interesting
dynamic at what point did and it was
this always the case were you kind of a
personal vlogger at the same time like
people know about your personal life as
much as you're willing to share through
your vlogs was that was that a dynamic
from the very beginning or was it that
kind of become something over time that
kind of snuck up on me there was a point
where I realized oh man you guys know a
lot about my life and in some ways I'm
totally fine with that and in other ways
I've realized that sometimes they're
there there's a specific type of viewer
that gets really upset when they find
out that I haven't told them something
hmm you know so that's been very strange
to navigate because on one hand it's
like well I I understand why you're
confused but at the same time I'm
entitled to some privacy you know No so
when it comes to disclosure via your
vlog channel and in connecting with your
your your fans your followers you
recently dropped like a bombshell and
everybody why don't you tell us about I
was so
Stout a nervous about making a video
saying that I had a boyfriend and and I
have never felt like there was so much
support in my community until now like
so that was the title I have a boyfriend
I have a boyfriend with a wide-eyed
smiley face yeah and a lot of people
thought because like you decided you
just I mean it sounds like you've been
pulling back into privacy but you
decided that this is something that you
were going on record with you were going
to be open yeah and not try but maybe
cry in the middle but yeah he I mean he
and I talked about it a lot and he first
of all tell everybody who your boyfriend
is oh my boyfriend is Sam Thorne aka
stripping from the yogscast and he's
been wonderful to me he and I have had a
yogscast meaning he he is a what does he
do he's a gamer too he's a gamer too
yeah so he's part of of a British
network called the augs cast and they
all do let's play gameplay videos and
they do big live streams and around the
holidays they do a live stream every
single day up until Christmas for
charity and it's good they're really
they're a really good group of people
and I wound up meeting him actually when
I when I went to England with Jesse and
he was one of those smelly guys who's no
he he and I talked about it a lot and we
were feeling feeling good about our
relationship and it's been a few months
and so we decided well rather than
rather than feeling the stress of of
needing to act like we're not super sir
yeah the stress of secrecy that's a good
way to put it
we decided that it was a good time to
just come out with it and see what
happens and so you got out you got a
positive response got a very positive
response everybody's very happy no no
messages Oh plenty plenty of mean
messages doesn't matter that they don't
they don't matter
no matter guys well I'm ready the tears
were tears of joy of happy so I mean it
takes a lot of me commas to overcome
that so yeah I'm happy for you thank you
so you ever cried in a vlog before yeah
I full-on cried in a vlog before because
uh there was man like at the beginning
of the year last year 2000 2013 I had
kind of a meltdown and in what way I
mean what uh I just had a lot of
personal issues going on and just had
like this major meltdown and and all of
my friends in LA had dropped what they
were doing and came over to like be with
me after seeing the vlog no no no I had
texted like like two of them being like
hey and and just like a bunch of people
came over to be with me and keep me
company and and got really emotional
about it and then I I wanted making a
video kind of saying you know I'm gonna
take a few days off like sorry about
that but I mentioned that all my friends
had been so amazing I just started
crying it's like stop but so those were
tears of joy - those were also tears of
joy I've I've never cried tears of
sadness on my show
they've always been tears I was private
and then publicly it was the the silver
lining mm-hmm that's great and did Sam
his name Sam yeah
did Sam also does he does he vlog is he
has sort of a personal flaw does he
strip I don't there's a little confusion
there so originally his gamertag
I love with a stripper that is a song is
that a song oh I should make it I should
make him a mixtape and it'll just be
that song over and over and over again
no a mixtape by definition needs more
than one song his initials RS T so as a
kid he made a game
that was st Ripon whoops I could have
ripped yay
and yeah turned out that that says
stripping right after you write it so
okay so but did he also disclose to his
fans mmm-hmm that he was dating you are
you sure because I couldn't find it
he did he did talk about it in a vlog
because I wanted to know if he was
crying too I had it no he did not cry
he was very whose room manly about it
but he knows that I have a closer
relationship with my fans so when we
were talking about how to go about
telling everybody he said well I think
that you should make I think that you
should make like B video because your
community is so close with you so but I
have to assume that there is amongst his
fans there's gonna be some jealousy I
mean that's just the way that it works
you know it's gonna be like oh he's
going out with Dodger I'm gonna send him
a message
you know he's got a few no but like it's
it's not it's not all that concerning I
don't think right youyou've obviously
developed a way of handling it knowing
that it is a reality that you are going
when you put yourself out there like
that and definitely as a woman putting
yourself out there in that atmosphere
you're gonna be a target somewhat mm-hmm
but it seems like you just it doesn't
get to you you you've made a decision to
be like I know this is part of the deal
mm but I am going to ignore it because
it is the minority that means sometimes
it's always gonna get to you yeah but
but that's what helps me get out of that
is remembering that that that is the
minority yeah and that the people that
that I am speaking to or the ones the
the nice wonderful ones you know so but
but in regards in regards to like any
negativity involving Sam like that's why
we waited so long to mention it in the
first place is because there's there's
that weird almost almost like Star
Magazine paparazzi feel to the whole
thing where it
if we were to talk about it too soon
when our relationship wasn't quite as
solidified we would be getting those
same messages and you know both be like
I don't I don't know like is she
cheating on me I don't know like you
know like all these weird messages that
are meant to mess with your head and so
we we decided to wait a little while
because that way we would get to know
each other better we would get to
solidify with a relationship a bit more
and you know when any any jealousy or
negativity came toward us we'd be able
to to deal with it as a unit rather than
than feeling kind of unsure of ourselves
right but the risk of sounding very
cheesy I'm gonna own this one but I draw
a correlation between your name Dodger
mm-hmm and the fact that you are you
found yourself in a position of like
Reza being a target so there's an art to
having me
either take take the blows or be able to
dodge them so it sounds like you're
navigating this zone pretty well The
Artful Dodger The Artful Dodger the
nickname came from is it huh I wanted to
get back to that oh yeah go to college
where did Dodger come from I was called
that when I was working on Dodger man
what's your first name what you've
wished what's the full spiel Brooke
Brooke Leigh Brookley Lawson is my full
name and when I was working in the scene
shop I had a co-worker who called me
Dodger after Artful Dodger and Oliver
Twist
so mostly because somehow I never died
in that scene shop like so many people
got hurt in there and I I was perfectly
fine and I don't know it's poetic that
it certainly applies to everything we've
been talking about about YouTube yeah
I'm just saying well this has been
extremely insightful yes and I'll be
counting sheep tonight thinking about
your sheep muscular there's no way to
not be weird about what it is
[Music]
and there you have it Brook Dodge early
Lawson
in full ear biscuit mode with Lee Lawson
which she said Brooke Lee lost and I
thought news anchor
this is Brooke Lee lossing lawsuit
coming to you live you know it's a good
name I mean Dodger that's a great name
is even better when you know you're
doing the video gig thing it's a cooler
more internetting name but I'm just
making the note that if she ever wants
to go back into newscaster you know the
fallback
Brooke Lee Lawson Baker
yeah Brooke Lee Lawson our mermaid
doesn't really sound like a I think you
would go with Dodger for that I I'd I
hope she wouldn't be offended if I'm
totally overwhelmed with the fact she's
so she's such a sweet person I don't
think she would that's not I mean that's
a compliment right I hope that she would
not be offended with me thinking that
she was a sweet person no I don't know I
think she's not like a sociopath so no I
don't think she would be offended by
that very strong person to I think when
you say that someone is sweet you don't
you say oh they're like it's like saying
that they're just like oh isn't that a
cute person versus but she's not that I
think we very well established that she
is has a lot of strength to be in the
environs that she is on the Internet and
that she can not only survive but can
and not only thrive but she can respect
her audience and she she believes the
best in them and chooses to ignore the
negativity that I mean I have to think
comes at her more often that Ana just
the typical guy who's doing gaming
content early internet yeah there's a
strength there there's a sweet strength
that I admire yeah I think that you know
I was definitely not surprised at all to
hear that you know traditionally this
was a 90/10 breakdown I mean first of
all in terms of men to women
show YouTube in general is there more
guys who watch youtube videos and more
guys who are on the internet on a
regular basis and you know habitually
[Music]
[Music]